[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my video for Star Wars the
Mandalorian Episode two hopefully you've
had a chance to see the first couple of
episodes by now the episode was crazy
short so if you thought something was
wrong and the episode was supposed to be
longer no it was supposed to be just a
little over 30 minutes I'll address that
at the end of the video too but there
was a whole bunch of Easter eggs and we
finally got some answers about what's
going on with the baby if you're new to
the channel I'm doing videos for all the
mandalorian episodes be sure to
subscribe to get everything I'm also
doing a Disney Plus giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite moment from the
episode on the video obviously careful
for spoilers if you have not seen the
episode yet will do top 10 WTF and
easter eggs as we go along starting with
number 10 the title of the episode was
the child the episode was mostly
inspired by this old Japanese manga
called lone wolf and cub mixed with a
classic old western train heist talking
about the jobless sandcrawler the story
of that lone wolf and cub manga is all
about a person named Ogami e - who's a
former executioner for a Shogun who's
disgraced after some false accusations
by another clan he's forced to take the
path of an assassin but has to take his
son with him so he's like a ronin
samurai carrying this child around him
while he's going from job to job just
like the Mandalorian is forced to go
collect on this bounty through the mud
horn while bringing this child and tote
with him most of the actors at the
premiere said that they referred to this
little puppet as baby Yoda but Jon
Favreau and Dave Fulani were like don't
call it baby Yoda too much we're trying
to keep this secret so it was amazing
that they were able to keep that from
leaking from the set because for the
most part they did use a practical
little puppet and then just touched it
up with a little bit of CG but I loved
how expressive they made it using body
language because clearly it can't speak
with words yet but it can still
communicate with its body language and
even Master Yoda
during the prequels during the original
trilogy when he gets excited or when he
gets upset about something or he's sad
he expresses with his ears
so anytime something bad happens to the
mandalorian you see him get kind of
worried his ears will lower down a
little bit when he sits up and shows
that he is alive his ears pricked back
up when he gets really excited because
he finds something to eat the little
frog on the ground his ears prick up
again because he's really happy so even
though he's still a tiny baby
developmentally even by his own species
standards he demonstrates a deep
intuition about his surroundings and he
can sense what people are feeling
through the force he's powerful enough
that using the force to him is just like
breathing to us but number nine the
transed ocean attack he's attacked by
three transed ocean bounty hunters at
the beginning of the episode on his way
back to the ship their only goal seems
like is to terminate baby Yoda one of
them almost gets it before he
disintegrates it with his rifle the
weapons that they attack him with the
stun batons that are on pole arms those
are called vibro weapons there are all
kinds of different vibro blades of
different sizes they can give up really
strong electric blasts they can vaporize
people or they can just be used to stun
people but number eight the problem of
the Imperials is getting worse he
notices a brand new bounty hunting
tracking Bob on the three trand oceans
realizing Werner Herzog's magistrate
character is sending more and more
bounty hunters after baby Yoda and it's
only gonna continue until he delivers
the baby to them and clearly from the
way this one charged baby Yoda trying to
kill it they're not after it to bring it
back alive so that wasn't clear when he
was actually negotiating his bounty for
best gar and he says I realized bounty
hunting is a complicated profession if
anything were to happen to it it's also
very wink-wink acceptable if you bring
back proof of termination I think some
people saw that and they're like no he
wants it back alive no he definitely
wants it dead it's the doctor that wants
the baby back alive because he seems
like he's connected to the cloning
facility at camino from attack of the
clones so if he recognized this symbol
he has it on his sleeve that was the
sleeve on all the clones at the Camino
facility and attack of the clones so
that's why everyone's thinking that this
baby might be a clone of Master Yoda so
when people call it baby Yoda
technically it might not be incorrect
even though it's not the original Yoda
either way every baby of his species is
incredibly force sensitive so it
wouldn't really matter if it wasn't Yoda
it would still be crazy powerful which
becomes more clear when seven baby Yoda
tries
to heal him using the force even though
he stops him twice it is kind of funny
to see how easily he's able to escape
that little baby carriage pod like it's
no big deal he just climbs right out
anytime he wants to him trying to heal
the mandalorian using the force is a bit
of a callback to obi-wan Kenobi healing
Luke after he'd been jumped by the sand
people in Star Wars Episode four we
learned later in the episode the
Mandalorians knowledge of force lore is
actually pretty weak he's still pretty
confused about what's going on with the
baby so it sounds like he didn't meet a
whole lot of Jedi during the Clone Wars
but remember from the flashbacks in
Episode one we know that that kid was
there during the Clone Wars so he's at
least heard tales of the Jedi and then
because of order 66 right after what was
happening here most of them were killed
off so it makes sense that he wouldn't
have run into that many Jedi during his
lifetime but number 6 WTF the Jawas gut
the razor crest huge WTF moment he
vaporizes a few with his rifle before
they take off and they begin the train
heist portion of the episode straight
out of an old western it was actually
kind of funny to see them just poof into
clouds of ash when he vaporized them to
baby Yoda even seems like he's enjoying
it here like he looks up at him like
he's kind of excited by what's happening
oh wow we're gonna go on a bit of a trip
here later in the episode when they go
to negotiate and he admits to
disintegrating a few of them that's
probably why they don't like me that's a
bit of a callback to Empire Strikes Back
when Darth Vader told Boba Fett no
disintegrations when they captured Han
Leia and Chewie bounty hunters really
like to disintegrate people when they
can number five the sandcrawler train
heist so as funny as it was watching him
go fold Donkey Kong trying to climb that
sandcrawler
while the job was her throwing stuff
down at him the whole time baby Yoda
following in the pod was even funnier he
seemed completely on board for whatever
they were doing no matter how dangerous
it seemed but just to explain how the
baby pod works they sort of explain
later in the episode - during the mud
horn fight it's slaved to his gauntlet
and is automatically set to follow him
wherever he goes
that's why later in the episode when
he's wrangling that giant horn bull
creature at the mud horn he waves his
gauntlet to dodge the pot away from it
it is just a standard baby pod there's
nothing really special about it
there were people after the ending of
episode 1 that wondered whether or not
baby Yoda
was levitating the pod using the force
orbit which is part of the technology of
the pot itself so this episode basically
answered that it's just built into the
tech of the pod it just hovers
everywhere it goes in the thing about
baby Yoda and this scene here - you can
clearly tell he's already attached to
the mandalorian he looks kind of worried
when he thinks that he might be dead
after he falls off the top of the
sandcrawler
but watch how he expresses when he sees
the Mandalorians sit up and sees that
he's alive when they go back to Nick
Nolte's ugh not character for help
there's also a funny Empire Strikes Back
reference when baby Yoda eats the Frog
yes it's just a funny visual gag but
it's also a reference to Empire Strikes
Back when they were making that movie
they were people on the crew that
referred to Yoda as a swamp frog and
then on the DVD commentary for Star Wars
attack of the clones George Lucas joked
that Yoda was the illegitimate child of
Kermit the Frog and Miss Piggy so it's
just a joke about Yoda being a frog so
baby Yoda eats the Frog but number 4 the
negotiation the jaw was telling me
speaks their language so poorly he
sounds like a Wookiee which is another
reference to the Star Wars Holiday
Special in the scenes with Boba Fett and
Chewbacca there's an r5 droid behind
them that's similar to the r5 droid the
Jabba's tried to sell to the large in
Luke Skywalker then they tell him that
he needs to find the egg of a giant
creature called the mud horn which is
kind of a bullish version of the reek
creature from Star Wars Attack of the
Clones
we also finally get to see the inside of
the control room of a Jawa sandcrawler
with the Mandalorian bumping his head
just to give us a sense for the scale
baby Yoda also seems very excited to be
here to number 3 the Mandalorian versus
the mud horn they go for a little bit of
a jump scare when he's in the cave in
just pitch-black darkness in that eye
opens right in front of him he gets his
ass handed to him he almost winds out
dying it's a little bit like an old
western with a cowboy trying to wrangle
a giant bull but the real WTF here is
number two baby Yoda using the Force to
own the mud horn just levitating it up
and it's a bit of a reference to Yoda
raising Luke Skywalker's x-wing out of
the swamp a very size matters not type
of lesson for the Mandalorian even
though he still doesn't totally
understand what's going on with baby
Yoda in the force
you also see during this - the baby Yoda
seems like it's really worried about the
Mandalorian in senses that he's in
trouble using the force from
even though he's still really tiny he
can still sense what other people are
feeling using the fort's the reason why
he passes out right after doing it is
because he's still technically a very
tiny baby even for his species he's not
old enough to even formally begin Jedi
training but that's how powerful he is
that he can do this at that very young
age they get the egg the Jawas just
start chomping down apparently it's just
a delicacy for them and that's all they
care about we just want some sweets give
us that sweet sweet giant hairy egg but
number one returning baby yoda to the
Imperials to collect on the bounty so
they have this montage of them putting
the razor crest back together is a very
patchwork ship which is meant to show
you how much he cares about the ship
like his relationship with his ship is
like Han Solo's relationship with the
Millennium Falcon it might seem like a
hunk of junk to Luke Skywalker first
glance but the Han Solo it's the most
important woman in his life for a good
long while till Leia comes along the
funniest thing about this scene - when
they're dragging the parts back if you
look at the side of the sled the job was
even stole his space toilet from the
ship which is just totally gross it's a
bummer that Nick Nolte's egg nog
character isn't gonna be with him in the
next couple of episodes maybe he'll come
back again later this season maybe he'll
come back during season 2 from all the
trailer footage they were hyping up it
seemed like he would be a bigger
character during the series because he's
got a full set of best gar armor in the
trailers and Werner Herzog is talking
about filming scenes with baby Yoda at
the premiere last week I'm assuming that
he collects on the bounty but it's
clearly not the end of his relationship
with baby Yoda and his importance in the
story is just the beginning also
addressing the short length of episodes
I actually thought that something was
wrong because when we got to this part
of the episode I checked to see how much
time was left and there was only a
couple minutes left in the episode so
I'm assuming the reason why episodes
have been so short is because one
they're super expensive to make they
spend about a hundred and fifty million
dollars making all eight of the episodes
but the other reason was also probably
because they weren't sure what season 1
was going to be and they made it in a
vacuum without any test screenings or
anything like that so they might be
correcting that for season 2 just
because the response has been so strong
so far but I don't know how long the
future episodes are going to be we'll
probably find out about that in the next
couple of weeks but here's a scheduled
update for all the rest of the episodes
it'll be a Friday show
the episodes are released a little after
midnight but my videos typically won't
post till midday so plenty of time to
watch let me know if there's any big
Easter eggs that you saw in the episode
that I didn't mention in the video I've
got some new Rick and Morty season 4 and
some new Marvel that I'll be posting
really soon congratulations Nick papel
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big Mandalorian video please email me on
the about page my channel so I can get
your contact details
everyone click here for the mandalorian
episode 1 video and click here for my
Rick and Morty season 4 episode 2 video
thank you so much for watching I have
spoken
you